thank you
[Music]
all right can anybody here name the uh
methods of execution lethal execution in
the United States yeah you got the
[ __ ] Lethal Injections lethal
injection
executions electrocutions
I think they bought they said the gas is
not yes
electric chair did we say that already
yeah the firing squad I think fire
squad's illegal no we should bring it
back okay you should hey how about
hanging I feel like they still do
hanging in some place I think yeah I
think so or I I would just like it to
happen what's a flogging what's a public
that's when you get [ __ ] hit with a
stick that's not death though is it no
you don't normally die all right so it's
uh it says uh thank you actually here we
go we got uh lethal injection 31 States
uh you can do lethal engines wow shout
out lethal injection in eight states you
can do electrocution
in seven states you can actually do
lethal gas oh seven huh I'd rather not
smell some [ __ ] in three states you can
do hangings wow
did it say what three states Delaware
New Hampshire and Washington hey I
wonder if they actually do it still New
Hampshire abolished the death penalty
but the repeal may not apply
retroactively leaving a prison on death
row facing possible execution by way of
hanging I believe whoa and then four
states Mississippi Oklahoma Utah and
South Carolina you can do firing squad
well can you choose oh wow I think they
should bring back is it by musket too oh
that'd be cool they should bring back
all of it it's all slow they gotta pour
in the [ __ ] gunpowder if they miss I
wonder if the firing squad they allow
the family members to do it
you know that the Poetic Justice don't
happen in our system why I don't like
this whole cruel and unusual punishment
thing yeah we want cool and usual cool
and very unusual one of my favorite is
when you tie the feet to the back of the
horse and go yeah
that's one of your favorites and then
the guys
that one's good it's either that or
you're tying horses to all the limbs
yeah oh yeah dude have you seen those
medieval like comic books or like art of
what they used to do in the torture
torture yeah I like the feather one
there's like the tech yeah the tickle to
death where they they literally just
have you [ __ ] like chained up like
bondage but then they just have a
feather next to the display and they're
talking about how they would just tickle
you to death how would you die like that
though are you ticklish it sure but not
after that 15 minutes hands up dude keep
your arms locked out right here is that
tickling no it's wet here
he's not ticklish I am ticklish but not
after 15 minutes you can't die like that
you get used to it I think it's more of
a torture chamber maybe that was like
one of the torture elements and then
death by just regulus or something I
don't know well you seem a little angry
about that I'm just angry that I just
touched you and there was no [ __ ] you
know what there's another thing that
tortured that I heard that it's called
are you reading my article
no no no then why is your point because
the torture chamber you you said torture
yeah it's a reference you want to just
fine I said I did all the pre-work now
you're gonna go ahead and dish out the
juice go ahead no I wasn't gonna say
what you want to say okay there's a
tortured thing it's called the oblige I
just saw it on Tick Tock yesterday is it
French they do that's what they said and
so what they do is they put you in a
hole really down uh like really deep but
it's above ground and then you can't sit
because it's so tight but then you could
smell and hear everybody's like having
fun and then they just let you be there
until you die holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's
in the today no no no no oh this is
today yeah we're talking whoa my bad
this is historical dude that's [ __ ] up
okay sorry that's like being an
intention when everyone else is on
recess I wouldn't want to kill myself
and not even being able to sit yeah and
you just gotta watch [ __ ] like two
two or three days straight and then
you're gonna die you're like in a bank
tube the one that sucks wow and then you
just have a little peephole that you can
see though yeah it's not even two or
three days it's stand till you die yeah
and you smell the the
um turkeys turkey specifically that was
no but I just thought that's a really
sad way to go man isn't there like a
slow drip one too where like they lay
you down and they have a little water
drip isn't it called like Chinese or
something it's where like eventually
like over time the water's just gonna
make a hole is that a real thing my mom
told me about like a medieval one like a
Chinese medieval one where they put you
and like a big ass like that of sesame
oil in a cave and they seal the cave so
if you just drink sesame oil you're
gonna have diarrhea right but then since
you're in the cave I'm so hungry you're
so hungry and dehydrated you force
yourself
I gotta drink something and it's very
good so you drink it and then you start
[ __ ] which makes you more dehydrated
so you drink any [ __ ] and just you [ __ ]
wow it's like forced dehydration that's
a real thing that's what she told me I
don't know oh my God I don't know why
she told me what a way to die have you
tried drinking sesame oil I love
something just like it smells so good
not until you die maybe the key is to go
like this and go
and savor it yeah you can't go crazy
that's how they thought of the word but
which one would you choose though would
you choose to like not drink it and then
just try to Die slow or you drink it and
then have diarrhea and die a little bit
faster
that's true that's true you can
extradite your your sentences or or or
try to dig yourself out oh yeah
but what if it's like a room
it's a cave what in this story is a cave
that's my mom said I don't know so if
it's a cave
so there's a U.S state that is going to
try a never-before used method of
execution oh [ __ ] in a world's first
Innovation let's go what is it what's
the new joints so Alan Eugene Miller is
a felon on death row in Alabama he may
be the first person to experience the
lethal death sentence by nitrogen
hypoxia what's that so that's gas that's
just another guess death nitrogen
hypoxia induces death by replacing
oxygen in the body with nitrogen so it's
basically light gas but it's nitrogen
hypo I mean why do they gotta come up
with something that new different gases
and [ __ ] why can't they just [ __ ] do
the whole and can you choose how you die
I want to choose so here's the actual
instance with this guy the reason why
it's even like potentially a first
experience that is Up For Debate or up
for a judge decision yeah it's this guy
is deathly afraid of needles so he
cannot take lethal injection in that
part who gives up all right Squad then
what the [ __ ] is that yo it depends on
what's legal in the state he's like I'm
a [ __ ] like rape 20 kids but I don't
like needles so please respect I'm sure
his victim was deathly afraid of death
yeah does it say what this person that's
why I don't get it hey these guys are
willing to commit cruel and unusual
crimes well guess what you should have
whatever's coming to you do we need to
start sentencing people to Antarctica
but what if he's a child with the
Penguins yeah what if they start
committing crime on the Block you gotta
watch out there's lots of penguins in
Antarctica I mean that's what they did
to the British criminals and then they
just became Australians true but they
had a whole continent at the time we're
running out of continents yeah so the
new method was approved in 2018 but has
not been used yet new method will be an
alternative to lethal injection which
has killed more than 1300 people in the
US since being introduced Miller who was
convicted killing three people in 1999
may be the first ever person to die at
the hands of the state with the nitrogen
hypoxia does it hurt uh it doesn't say
because we think it's probably I think
it's probably painless I think you just
probably slowly get put to sleep yeah
it's like a freaking Animal Hospital it
says the convicted murder requested the
alternative method of death as it's
understood he is afraid of needles
Miller has to overcome another obstacle
fee is to have his death wish
Corrections commissioner John Hamm has
to approve the execution method in time
and the convicted killer has previously
applied to die by nitrogen hypoxia with
lawyers for the inmate filing a lawsuit
last month claiming that he had turned
in a form selecting nitrogen but the
State lost it now [ __ ] shouldn't
have rights man whatever happened to a
good old-fashioned strangle there they
killed they've already killed 20
[ __ ] yeah yeah why can't they
die like the way that their victims did
that's like the easiest way okay but how
many though but if they killed two
people and they're like
I don't want to kill people anymore I'm
a good person though
you have to kill him dude you have to
kill him but what do you mean like if a
person killed two one person and they're
like you know what I want to kill one
more person that's it and then they say
after that you know Mark do you give
them the past that's what that's what I
was asking you guys
that's one that's one word I would say
how did they how did he kill him okay is
it was it by accident what's the
acceptable killing yeah well no we're
not we're not talking about involuntary
manslaughter right so self-defense okay
one is the second one was self-defense
but the first one was he was angry for
fun selfish angry they got a Starbucks
order wrong why did he kill somebody
aggravated assault if okay if he killed
somebody if he killed someone because he
lost his anger
then I think that guy was the source of
his injure yeah I mean the guy's dead
now he's not angry anymore I think we
should hire him as one of the props for
the describe the destruction room so
when you're angry you want to take out
your anger you cannot hit this guy oh
that's tight because he killed somebody
out of anger so that means other people
can kill you out of anger what okay no
no he must fit the crime okay fine but
does he die or no yeah because he can't
kill somebody the person
in there you know really angry Mike
Tyson yeah you make fun of him so you
put this guy you empty out a punching
bag and you put him inside and then you
make fun of Mike Tyson and his [ __ ]
pigeons and then he comes and he beats
the [ __ ] up
yeah you know it's kind of an unusual
thing they did back in I think the 90s
is when hackers got in trouble they made
it illegal for them to use the internet
oh really I think they still do that
which is like I think now it's there's
[ __ ] no way they can police that yeah
you go to a library they believe they
could do that to you wow and and I
remember I was watching a video about a
guy who got that sentence and he was
saying he wanted to kill himself
he's so Elite and so like knowledgeable
about this thing he can never use that's
pretty [ __ ] that's harsh right that
is Harsh holy [ __ ] but now there's no
way you can think and stop you yeah
that's it
you my friend know how to do an outro
man
[Music]